io devo capire chi è l'ospite segreto
chi è che lo sa secondo te guglielmo
devo capirlo chi è il mostro il segreto
e nove e mezza patti alza discesa cosa
stai facendo
glielo ospite segreto non mi guardano
come c'è segreto allora se vuoi ti posso
dire è già stato all'interno del canale
di willwoosh ma intanto dc ma è una
donna un uomo è già stato all'interno
del canale a quale canale è già stato
uguale camerano di questo canale che
state guardando in cui sarah non il
canale quando ma come potete svegliarmi
ci vediamo fra tre o le domando alla
buon fine va beh
mentre mi sveglio con questi due sì così
romas numero 3
yellow
tecnica todini a quel mostro a parte che
non sa discernere ti ha rilasciato con
quella fuori minieri abbandonare tutto
quanto secondo granelli diritti erano
ovunque e quelli sono anche gli strinse
di capua ogni mattina vestito da da
regina a fare la serba ogni mattina a
stimare che sotto sotto ti diverte tutto
questo fra realta un pochino sì però è
un selvaggio il tuo gatto
detto questo c'è un altro problema che
io non riesco a capire non sapevi
sostituirlo
così bastava fare allentando la presa
certo che no
credo che cui el morando abbia preso in
antipatia il mio figlio letto per rega
questa è guerra
ecco adesso però devo intaccare punto ti
si mangia cerco la cosa è tanto la
scodella di quasi tutta piena della tua
bava appunto bravo bravo bravo
bravissimo che da via bozzini poveri su
quell essere al mio diletto buon pranzo
scendiamo tempere pigiama potere sempre
punto mi sa che cosa lo faremo prende
spazzatura non lo sto posto questo stop
risale al quinto piano questa rosa in
terrorizza ma devo fare
no no no non ci credo non sia così mi
sono bloccato l'ascensore
no non ci credo
guido siamo bloccati in ascensore sono
bloccati in ascensore
forse con la chiamata ripartiti ragazzi
che ho avuto il migliore in cui dopo
avuto il terrore ha sventato andiamo
prende la spazzatura però prima dai
vieni a piedi saremo propri editori in
poi sono risaliti dell'ascensore la sola
kakà ce la faccio a fare i cinque sono
rimpianti
eccoci qua adesso sì dunque in cina
cantieri sul mito che sta presso decessi
fa spazzatura ok che abbastanza critica
però nello stesso dando maledetti allora
posso dire questa tassazione è già
partito con la sensazione di sfida
nell'aria portare culto è forse la cosa
più tranquilla oggi a sta mangiando la
merda e intende stava mentendo tavo
chiaramente mentendo
ma che è arrivato è pazzo ecco semmai
non sentire
simpatiche
[Musica]
[Applauso]
difettoso non riuscito a bucare laga
banche ma mica tanto sto coso
l'attivazione 7 volendo questa galletta
fesa di tacchino
ma aggiunge offre solo un piccolo sapevi
che il tuo bibitone greco paga paga o
non ci credo da guardare ma se mangiando
masismo dove assaggiare allora c'è tutti
sta mangiando real ha mai sondhi la
pizza diventino rosso lacca banca imi
della per come dell'altro a gabon sa
bene su tutto io e latte non lo stato
con la campania è abbastanza il counter
pamela 32
non è una capatina morte di rio
nell'assaggio senza audio senza odio e
di maniera che mette division presidente
aquino è dai bambini
no no no ma il varo di gocce
un mondo troppo disturbi fondata dai
mimica e mali come è un è la cosa più
buona che dovrebbero mangiare elemento è
delizioso ma non è da potresti sentire
un leggero senso di euforia da un altro
sapore comeback si trasforma i favori né
vale per unreal placamento a kabanga
delizioso con dio
lasciamo il link per acquistare la banca
sotto il video vi lasciamo il link qua
sotto facendo ma questi sono per curdo
queste cose quando in cielo mi posso
fare un burger
no e neanche questo oppure questo
tributo ma questo frigo che solo cibo
per animali che ma come si gli animali
sono per noi stiamo mangiando patatine e
il gruppo si mangia il sì non mangiato
il cibo di cultura si mangia la scottona
allora voi cominciate niente non toccato
il cibo di cui veramente sono
esterrefatto e comunque e non tutti gli
animali sono i più importanti che ho
tirato quasi ott io avrò il mio poter o
il tuo blog ma un selvaggio
[Applauso]
il cinese
l'ostacolo di un secondo poverino come
fai a u d arma riuscì di rimanere ferita
piccolo mio di regali una kabanga dei
comprati 2 che ci devi fare è natale
regala meno uno
hai altre richieste la casa in questo
gatto il marini
ragazzi siete matti non dovete rassa
cibo in giro maleducati era maleducati
indica io sto con la rete di posa l'uomo
anche io la chance guardano mannini ora
mi piace [ __ ] per la seconda volta
gironcino adesso amore il tuo preferito
dentro questa siamo di appositi insieme
prego sono arrivati a doni che amazon
con decorazioni cosa un po come no laga
banca è bastato capitale no ci sono
tutte le colazioni raga domani si fa
l'albero non mi interessa niente ho già
portato dalle relazioni a casa mia ma
siccome quest'anno facciamo un albero di
due metri e mezzo avevo bisogno di più
con decorazioni una sorpresa lei è super
ma quindi era lei l'ospite segreto
no non è né lo spiego segreto lei è
normale lei è perché sono stanco di
sparare non river delegati non la
considerano si può bisogna pulire di
bullet è venuta con noi pagare ciò di
merda e anzi sarà una vacanza di merda
perché va con dal legale noi ma rimani
qui tutto il mese se veramente una certa
pensato di regalarvi una schiava maretta
[Applauso]
[Musica]
avvisi di piccola benedetta nana mia
mamma valentina ben toccato il fondo al
corridoio siete contenti questo è il
bagno o tre volte al giorno vado per
contagio è proprio la pista questa casa
piena di porti e allora sessantina
cucina male la colazione alle 9 lanzone
30 a tutta vita proprio queste sono le
nostre stanze alte volte che i nostri
sforzi fatti
lei starà dietro questa tenda e allora
ecco quale abbiamo anche un figlio a
breve per testare la madre surrogato che
zaia che però è benvenuta grazie
mangiato
se dovessi descrivere l'arrivo di
valentina con una sola parola direi
delusione sono veramente veramente
deluso o carissima per tutti lo sei mio
preferito quindi puoi scegliere bene e
non ci crederanno il mio colore
preferito ora vediamo come tu ben sai
voglio dire no vabbè ma grazie mille no
no sono troppo contento davvero grazie
ciao ces è chiaro e non è che sia
proprio felicissima di avere valentino
al contempo però perché con l'infinito
però mi serviva una mano a mano che poi
grazie carina e scegliere visto che sei
il mio preferito puoi scegliere quale
vuoi
secondo voi quale voglio quest'albero
hai capito come mi conosci bene quanto
mi piacciono le palle mamma mi accade
guido sei pronto a divorare dai mille
varianti al sen
sto facendo un pochino di blog
tournament iii
ciao pichini come dei cretini anno è
carino che renault quello che avevo
immaginato come un dono di vendetta nei
confronti di guglielmo improvvisamente è
diventato un piano di conquista
dell'impero infatti come ben potete
vedere eto'o è qui con me e quindi che
cosa è un cerchietto viaggio amore
bellissimo
sta molto bene l'inquadratura è
bellissimo ragazzo è stato già ora
grazie a dopo ma che è stata tracciata
ragazzi cui elmo ci ha fatto tanto all
ospite segreto illusione
non c'è da immaginare stato molto felice
della mia presenza
grazie a tutto il tabù si no ragazzi a
me sembravano tutti contenti era un po
in ansia metto detto vabbè sarà una
delusione che arrivo io che cenò
sembravano tutti contenti soprattutto
dei cerchietti la v non se n'è più tolto
quindi sono super contento mi hanno
detto di dirvi che ci vediamo domani
alle 14 su youtube e questa sera dalle
19 su tweet